foreign
all right we do now know the dates that
both Tropicana and the I-15 will be
completely closed next month
Tropicana will be closed between D
Martin and New York New York from
January 22nd until January 30th the I-15
will be shut down between Flamingo and
Russell from 10 pm January 27th until 5
a.m January 30th the Nevada Department
of transportation's Justin Hopkins it's
not just Lane restrictions and it's not
just a traffic headache it is actually
full stop 24 7 closures of Tropicana for
eight days and of I-15 for three full
days n dot Project Director Lynette
Russell once we close Tropicana on the
22nd it is very much about removals
um it will be when she says removals
they're talking about removing the start
of the flyover ramp from the south 15
that fly over to go east on Tropicana
that is going to be taken away now we're
going to have a lot more on this as the
dates get closer but it's not being
called drop a canner for nothing and
endot is hoping that you'll consider
downloading the I-15 Drop app you'll
have everything you need to know at your
fingertips buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone you can join
the driving you crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com